Et c'est parti !
Les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'un sujet qui me tiens à cœur
Et en fait je vais vous raconter une histoire
avant de commencer
Une histoire bien évidemment en rapport avec la vidéo
avec ce qu'on va faire juste après l'avoir raconté vous en faites pas
C'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui s'appelait Hauchard Lucas
Et cet enfant avait beaucoup de mal à différencier le bleu du rose du gris
Voilà c'est la fin de l'histoire, c'était très court *rires*
Alors, les amis je pense être daltonien mais vous savez il y a plusieurs degrés de daltonisme
Ça concerne différentes couleurs etc BREF
Et moi j'ai du mal avec les couleurs comme le bleu, le rose, le gris.
Voilà c'est, je sors ces exemple là car c'est les trucs les plus flagrants
Et je me suis embrouillé plusieurs fois avec des gens de ma famille
Parce que je disais NON, ce truc est rose !
Et ma famille me faisait
"Bah non Lucas, vraiment c'est bleu hein"
TA GUEULE C'EST ROSE !
Et c'était avant que je découvre ce qui était le daltonisme, tout simplement
Le daltonisme, c'est génétique
ça veut dire que y'a forcément quelqu'un de ta famille qui te l'a transmis
Bref, quelqu'un m'a envoyé par mail ce site: Enchroma
qui te permet de faire un test de ta vision des couleurs.
Je crois que ça consiste juste à voir des chiffres dans des trucs de couleurs
Là par exemple je vois pas.C'est normal j'pense
Là y'a un 5 par contre
Start test!
Instructions
Tu vas voir une image composée de petits points
Tu pourras voir l'image que pendant quelques secondes
Tu dois trouver le nombre caché dans les amas de points
Ce sera un chiffre compris entre 1 et 9
Clique sur le bouton approprié pour indiquer ce que tu as vu
Ok, bah y'a pas plus simple c'est niquel
Ok, z'est parti
Alors, là c'est un 1
On voit très clairement, ah ouais putain si tu vois pas le 1 je pense que c'est que t'es un daltonien vénère.
Je connais pas les noms des différents types de daltonisme
mais il se différencie juste par le fait que y'en a qui voient pas le vert,
y'en a qui voient pas le rouge,
y'en a qui voient pas... Enfin voilà c'est... Comment dire?
la perception de certaines couleurs est altérée.
mais c'est pas toujours les mêmes qui sont altérées
'FIN BREF
Bon c'est un 1, clairement, on va pas se mentir
*sonnerie de téléphone*  OHOHOH
oui allo?
Bonechour
Bonjour?
Bonjour, je suis Sabrina votre conseillère SFR
Très bien
Euuuh alors *rires*
Nan mais mec, ils m'appellent
trois fois par jour
depuis dix jours
j'en ai marre
En plus je suis même plus chez vous
LAISSEZ MOI EN PAIX PUTAIN
ARRETEZ DE FORCER LA
alors
en plus c'est important ce qu'on est en train de faire
c'est un 6, c'est évident
AH! La changé de couleur,  maintenant c'est du rouge sur du... vert
putain j'aimerais bien qu'ils expliquent à chaque fois
si tu vois pas le chiffre, là par exemple, quel type de daltonisme tu as
là ça va, c'est un 8
WHAAAA
J'ai beaucoup de mal là
mais bon, je pense que vous aussi
mais bon, au final c'est un 8, ça se voit
*rire nerveux* Dafuck
Ah mais non ya un bouton "rien", ok
là y a rien
ok putain ils m'on fait peur
ça c'est un neeeeuf
un sept
putain c'est flagrant
quand c'est du bleu sur du vert je le vois super bien
c'est bizarre parce que c'est les couleurs dans la vrai vie qui me posent un peu problème
là c'est un 1
je vais super vite en vrai
ATTENDS!
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a un chiffre à voir
et j'ai l'impression que plus je m'éloigne
mieux je vais le voir
non y'a rien, y'a rien
ici y'a des trucs un peu rosés mais ça forme pas un chiffre
WHOW
là ça commence à être...
j'crois qu'ya un 5 là !
ça commence à être suuuper difficile putain
c'est terrible!
bon y'a un 5, clairement
là ya un 2
c'est un 6? c'est quoi?
on dirais un S, ou un 0
c'est un 6 les amis, bien sûr c'est évident que c'est un 6
c'est un 7
nan mais attend
quand c'est flagrant comme ça c'est impressionnant
n’empêche John Dalton, le mec qui a découvert le daltonisme
parce qu'il était lui-même daltonien
c'est pas le mec qui à dû le plus embrouiller un gars au MONDE
la robe est bleu, la robe est rose
eux ça a duré deux heures
lui la robe il a maintenu qu'elle était rose mais pendant dix jours
Alors là, y'a rien
'tin mais là c'est tellement flagrant
ça pour moi si tu vois pas le 3 c'est que t'as un type de daltonisme assez vénère, j'pense
là y'a un 6
là y'a rien
si y'a un 3, y'a un 3
oh putain
C'EST CA  QUE JE VOIS MAL! C'EST CA!
Et là je le vois plus le 3
OH NOOON
c'est ça que je vois grave mal
oh putain
donc c'est bien vert-bleu quoi
Oh merde!
Là y'a rien, là y'a rien arrêtez de me prendre pour un con quand même
3, ouais
1, ouais
ciiiinq, ça aussi j'ai un peu de mal mais ça va
là c'est le 7
4, bien évidement
Hé les amis, ça doit pas être très palpitant pour vous
mais je suis tout excité de voir du coup ce que je vais avoir en fait
comme type de daltonisme
Oh merde! putain c'est quoi ça? oh merde!
*bruitage de verre que l'on essuie*
*un autre, plus fort*
énorme imitation du mec qui essuie ses lunettes, n'est-ce pas?
non c'est un 4
là y'a rien
là y'a un 2
non là ça commence à être suuuper dur à voir, hein, vraiment hein
ça m'étonnerait pas qu'il y ait pleins de gens d'entre vous
qui arrivent pas non plus à voir les chiffres mais qui soit pas pour autant daltoniens
y'a un... 5
olala mais mec c'est d'une difficulté à voir là
c'est incroyable
mec je dois me concentrer sa mère
c'est terrible
Wha là c'est tellemement
nan blague, blague, BLAGUE
c'est un 1, bien sur
c'est re un 1?
ouai, c'est re un 1
What the FUCK?
Attends mais en plus j'suis con d'me lever
parce que quand tu te lèves ou quand tu te baisse
les couleurs de l'écran elles sont pas pareille
nan c'est vrai
quand t'es en bas c'est plus sombre
quand t'es au dessus c'est plus lumineux
je vous apprends des choses
je saurais pas l'expliquer mais je vous apprends des choses *rires*
AH!
j'crois que c'est fini
je suis "Mild Deutan"
Alors les Deutan sont les gens avec la deutéranomalie
C'est une mauvaise perception des couleurs rouge et vert
non mais attend mais...
franchement j'arrive pas à y croire c'est sûr et certain que tout les gens qui ont regardé la vidéo
ils ont eu du mal aux trucs où c'était rouge sur vert aussi
nan?
ah je sais pas, je dis ça mais ça se trouve, pas du tout
oh putain c'est marrant
donc mes cônes qui sont censé détecter le vert le détecte pas assez
et par contre ils sont trop sensibles au jaune, à l'orange et au rouge
du coup le vert, le jaune, l'orange et le rouge et le marron vous paraissent similaires
pas du tout mec, mais alors pas du tout
surtout en basse lumière
encore moins
il peut aussi être difficile de trouver la différence entre le bleu et le violet
ou le rose ou le gris
AH BHA LA OUI
bha là oui mec
c'est drôle
là ça correspond, après est-ce que c'est le hasard ou pas mec?
Ah c'est dur là parce que la première partie du résumé ne me correspond pas...
'fin ou alors j'ai pas spécialement remarqué ma difficulté à différencier le...
le jaune, le vert, le orange, le rouge
mais par contre, ce qu'ils ont dit après, le bleu et le violet, et le rose et le gris mec
c'est... c'est ça c'est le rose et le gris
Ah putain, ah putain
Vous savez quoi? on va appeler ma grand-mère et on va lui demander:
quelle couleur, mon grand-père avait du mal à voir?
Allo?
Comment tu vas?
ça va et toi?
bha ça va très bien
en fait j'ai fait une vidéo où je faisais un test de daltonisme
oui?
et, ils me disent que en gros j'ai du mal à différencier
le bleu et le violet, et le gris et le rose
est-ce que tu te souviens papy euh, quelle couleur il avais du mal à voir
et bien lui, avec les bleus, les bleus et les gris, ça c'était sûr hein
bas c'est marrant parce que c'est exactement comme moi
à chaque fois qu'on allait chercher un vêtement il voyait jamais la couleur, hein
*rires* vous avez eu des embrouilles plusieurs fois?
NOOON on était pas d'accord bien sûr
il soutenait qu'il voyais ça, puis c'était pas la bonne couleur hein
il était têtu?
ah oui, oula
bha voila, bha c'était cool que tu t'en souviennes
quand il achetait des costumes on était jamais d'accord
ah c'est rigolo
bon bha voila, c'est un mystère d'élucidé grâce à toi
donc je te remercie et puis je te dis à très vite ma mamie
oh bha j't'en prie
j'te fais pleins de gros bisous ma mamie
bon bha gros bisous à toi et puis bonne journée hein
bha toi aussi, bisous ma mamie
allez à bientôt
à bientôt, je t'aime, bisous
AH! elle est pas incroyable moricette? elle est mignooone
Oh avouez, avouez on a tous envie de la câliner
Etbenlesamisc'estdéjalafindecettevidéon'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous à plu
eh bien écoutez, j'ai, je... suis très content parce que j'ai trouvé ce que j'ai
donc en fait c'est juste une mauvaise perception de la couleur verte
je vais me faire un café et je vous dis, à bientôt!
Sous-titres réalisé bénévolement par Blue Stone
En espérant  qu'ils ne soient pas trop mauvais vu que c'est ma première fois
Tshus! :p